the US military moved key parts of a
controversial missile defense system
into position overnight in South Korea
police held back protesters lining a
roadway as trucks brought in the defense
system known as bad the accelerated
deployment comes as North Korea released
the first pictures that appear to show
yesterday's massive artillery drills
Adriana Diaz is in Beijing Adriana good
morning good morning that has become one
of the most controversial issues in the
region and it's early deployment today
took South Koreans by surprise hundreds
gathered before dawn throwing water
bottles at the military trailers
carrying sections of the missile defense
system at least ten were reportedly
injured during clashes with police
the South Korean government believes fad
is a necessary defense against an
increasingly aggressive North Korea that
aggression was on display again Tuesday
as Kim jong-un presided over what North
Korea claims was its largest live-fire
drill ever despite fearing more missile
tests from Pyongyang Beijing strongly
opposes that fearing it could spy on
China and called again today for Thad's
removal Alex Adriana Diaz in Beijing
thanks